have you ever optioned or bought a
screenplay III have options in but
screenplays yeah under treasure
entertainment oh ok for I went freelance
I'd yeah we used to all the time and a
lot of them came from our clients as
well do you take us through the process
sorry yeah so you know in terms of at
least when you know in treasure
Entertainment when we would part of what
I liked about managing clients is you
had this in-house table of talent that
you could draw from so if we had
identified something in the market you
know an opportunity or some reason we
wanted to do a certain type of picture I
you know had clients in-house I said hey
what about one of these ideas because
this is something that we're thinking
about doing if we can develop this with
you and get it to the point where I
think it's strong maybe we'll option it
from you guys or well well you know
we'll buy it so not to say we didn't
chop around but it kind of allowed us to
just get exactly what we wanted working
with the writer and then getting it to
okay this movie want okay well option it
no I supposed to scour in the
marketplace trying to find that exact
kind of thing we wanted but yeah I mean
once once we identified a strong project
either something that we came across or
something that we had a client create
with our help
the optioning process was you know
pretty simple I mean you know a lot of
times we just do you don't want your
option with with a you know when you're
renewal period and you know whatever
sort of modicum of depending on the size
of the film mean options can be we pay
anything from a dollar just to you know
if it's you know real development writer
and they're like look I just want to get
it out there and it's like all right
let's just see if we can get this thing
out here we're putting our sweat equity
into it so it might just be a $1 you
have to have something called
consideration there has to be something
from this side going to this side to
make it legal and even if that's a
dollar here's a dollar here's your
script and an option is just basically
saying you know you can't sell it to
anyone else
during this beer we have the exclusive
right to chop it to set it up or to buy
it during this period and if we exercise
the option here will give you $10,000
$20,000 whatever whatever the amount is
and then the option is exercised so it
gives us the option to
exclusively for that period or we might
have optioned things up to a naught
thousand bucks or two thousand bucks I
mean just depending on the size of the
project it was all indie stuff so you
know I mean they weren't getting $10,000
options but you know it's 500 bucks or
whatever it is and then that applies
against the purchase price so if you opt
in something for five hundred bucks and
you're gonna buy the script for 20 grand
that 500 is typically applied against
the 20 so you pay the 19 5 if you decide
to buy it although those deals can be
structured however you know however you
want so yeah I think that was that's
kind of how how we approached it was hey
in-house talent awesome and because we
were their managers and they saw all the
sweat equity we were putting into trying
to get their career off the ground in
the project a lot of times we could
option a script for a lot less than if
we had just found it and they didn't
know well something like well I want
$3,000 for this you know we had already
built this relationship and and so it
was a good you know it was a good system
and worked for us what about life story
rights yeah I'm working on a project
right now actually called walking on
Paul Meadows with yeah writer Jim
Christelle and Ed Asner you know it's
like screen legend good old Edie and the
story is based on a real-life person
miles Richards who's very actively
involved in the project as well as an
executive reducer and he had met Jim
many years ago through a mutual friend
and Jim Thomas guys stories so
interesting he sat down he interviewed
him like a tape recorder for hours I
mean I don't know who's like maybe a
couple days worth of interviews but they
you know he got out he's like wow this
guy's story is so interesting and
decided you know this is the kind of
story that that would make a great at
first I think he was thinking about a TV
show but then he decided to let me make
this into a script a feature script and
I got involved when Jim came to me and
asked me to do a budget as a pretty
fairly large picture I would say it's
like almost maybe even studio mid-level
kind of budget and I got you know did
the budget and he and Jim was very happy
with the work and decide a skiff
come on and as a producer and work with
work with him on it and I you know I
came on board and I asked him I said you
have the miles life rights this guy
miles extraordinary you know kind of
human being he was he was actually a
marijuana smuggler and had started when
he was like 21 or something in smuggled
his first like you know batch of
marijuana from Jamaica he was working on
the Playboy Club his father his father
on the construction coming I was
building the Playboy Club in Jamaica and
he went there for a summer to work on it
and that's where he got involved in
marijuana and started smuggling it and
his first load when he was like 21 even
me like a quarter million dollars
there's in the 60s oh wow
and so right so the thing about Myles
was he never did a load the same way
twice he always there's always some
innovative way and the script goes the
story goes into a couple of these movies
there were so many different ways but
but like he sank a ship off the coast of
Florida on purpose loaded with water
sealed bags of marijuana filed for a
permit to do a salvage operation so the
Coast Guard got to know him and then
every you know their salvaging bringing
up parts of the boat with you know
marijuana in it and the Coast Guard's
like right there and they had no idea he
came with these ingenious so it took the
DEA like 15 years to even know who he
was another five years to catch him and
you know it's very much catch me if you
can
Goodfellas like that tonally like the
likeable criminal should follow over in
wolf awal so you follow over 20 years of
their life kind of that kind of arc and
their comeuppance and sort of you know
the sort of life trajectory as miles did
go to prison he was there for 11 years
he was in solitary confinement for four
years came out a very different person
then he started a whole legal business
and construction became a millionaire
illegally but it was a really
interesting story and I asked you have
Myles life rights for this and he didn't
I said well that's the first thing we
need to do and so you know we we went to
Myles and at that point we had already
worked with him long enough that he knew
us and trusted us I mean I had talked to
on the phone I've never met him
personally but I talked him on the phone
Jim had you know been dealing with him
for years and so I had a life rights
option drafted up and you know Myles
signed off on it
I mean we had certain agreements with
him that we wouldn't while we can take
creative license that there were certain
things we wouldn't do miles want to make
sure the smuggling was depicted
realistically it's like look just don't
have anybody running around with a
suitcase of a million dollars that looks
like this he's like I know what a
million dollars looks like in a suitcase
of fifteen hundred dollar bills and it's
not like what they look like in these
movies where it's you know these big
suitcases stacked to the brim with
hundreds and he's like that's not what a
million like they're just stuff like he
wanted us to stay true to a lot of the
aspects even if we took creative license
with let's say some of the FBI guys that
were chasing him or his lawyers in the
script there's one named lawyer that
sort of deals that deals with his case
but he's an amalgamation of many lawyers
in real life there was many lawyers it
wasn't this one guy so things like that
were okay but he wanted to make sure the
smuggling was was treated accurately and
so you know we agreed to the things that
he wanted and yeah he signed off on that
life rights option it really gave us
creative control of the project and and
the ability to sort of take this take
the story within those bounds within
those parameters where we wanted to and
so just as an option expires then
someone's life rights expire as well and
then they're free to use them with
another production company could we have
it and so that we have a certain term
and then it automatically renews for
extended periods unless one of us
cancels it so long as the miles is happy
I mean it's gonna keep renewing unless
he gives us written notice within you
know 30 days of when the expiration is
fascinating yeah yeah and when does that
come out by the way well we're working
we're working to are trying to get it
off the ground
for top of 2019 in terms of production
so this is this is I mentioned earlier
project we were looking at possibly
shooting in Australia there's maybe some
tax incentives we can take advantage of
plus a lot of the picture takes place in
Southern California and the Caribbean
and so Australia has locations that can
really play for both because the
Caribbean really looks very different
than Southern California you know
Caribbean is very flat white sands
different type of palm trees different
type of water just a different outlook
the the people I mean it's very
different but yet Australia I think has
options for us that can play for both so
that's something we've been looking at
you